my understanding is that you sought out
the safty brothers who directed this
movie you had become kind of very
intrigued by them and wanted to meet
with them as opposed to vice-versa first
uh well yeah I kind of one of the sort
of most strangely impulsive decisions
I've made I hadn't seen any of their
work I just saw one photograph from the
last movie and basically send them a
obsessive fan letter what was it about
that photograph it was just instinct I
mean it was just I was kind of I don't
do anything apart from let's go on like
look through film review websites
someplace and I saw this one photo tree
stuck out and it looked like normally
the blurb would be you know kind of
check direct hungarian director blue and
i would look down and realize they were
american and based in new york i just
kind of like all if their sensibility is
the kind of thing that would release
this one photo as their first
promotional still i just really really
liked the idea of meeting them and then
basically agreed to do this movie when
there was no script there was nothing
and they hadn't even thought of this as
an idea they're doing a different movie
and they just came back with this
initial squared which was just
phenomenal and kind of went from there
and i was shocked as someone who wasn't
that familiar with them to realize very
early on that benny one of one half of
the directing team is the actor who
plays Nick your brother as well and he
is phenomenal unbelievable and people
literally see him doing a cue and I also
it's and still don't understand I've
been fun just pretty great and my
understanding is that he in some ways
stayed in that character even as he was
going about some of his directorial
duties yeah well and he was only there's
some things when he was holding the boom
as well while simultaneously being in a
scene which is like I've never seen
anyone multitask
better yeah they can do everything and
he also edited the movie and he also had
a baby a week before we started shooting
his first kid his insanity all right I
mean I guess the highest compliment I
can pay to you is if I had no idea who
you were before seeing this it would
never have crossed my mind that you were
not from Queens amazing what right can
you describe how you kind of got into
this New York state of mind this the the
vibe of it I also understand you guys
wrote letters to each other you and
Benny wrote letters to each other in
character and came up with very
extensive biographies of the characters
what all went into it yeah I mean those
along was a long process and because
there wasn't really a script at the
beginning it kind of being able to see
the script come together in the
character come together in the writing
in to the piecemeal chunks it kind I
just sort of got an idea of what that I
whether I wanted to go with it and I
could kind of start to hear it start
hearing the characters voice kind of
very very slowly instead of just trying
to learn an accent and I'm just applying
it to the words it's also there from
Queens and so it's people don't really
realize it's very subtle differences in
the way someone writes dialogue it's
written in Queens accent it's released
to my ear anyway you know what a quaint
accent I mean now I mean I know I did I
knew what the accent was with all the
people I was hanging around with in
Queens a lot and I just spent maybe like
two months just kind of basically
staying in the same accent and the same
kind of body language and but yeah just
having the amount of time and it's all
loved any accent it's kind of I think
it's like it's like a lot of times to
reverse-engineer a character when you
think of a voice first and there's also
this this dialogue which they write it's
just really fun to say and you're
excited about saying which I think is it
it's the best sestet with a character do
you have a recollection of the first
full wardrobe and hair test or the first
time you really saw yourself in a mirror
as Connie and what that feeling was like
I mean we've done a bunch of tests we've
done me and Benny went we were sort of
improvising in character just in the
real world a lot to see kind of kind of
vaguely trying to come up with costume
ideas and that what people would believe
and here we have spent we got jobs in a
carwash and Brooklyn and I think it's
just working a 24-hour car wash and
stuff and just kind of it was
interesting to me because I kept
thinking that someone's going to be like
oh you're an actor it's obvious and I
the amount of time just kind of with
certain costumes and certain just
behavioral things like all people people
might sort of vaguely recognize
something but they don't really they
weren't really questioning it and so I
was thinking like this is kind of crazy
though but yeah I can't i but up until
the first day was the first scene which
I did was breaking Benny out of the
psychiatrist office it's terrifying I
mean I was literature so I don't know
what this part is there anything and and
luckily the power kept going out and the
hospital was shooting in and so it kept
getting the first take are going to late
and delayed and delayed and delayed and
so I was just hiking myself up to the
point of I've been kind of pumping up my
Adrenaline's of for hours before he
started shooting is completely like the
red mist had really fallen so it didn't
really have a chance to think about
anything and then realized after that
like oh I had to sort of maintain this
level the next seven weeks would you say
the majority and people in this movie
were non-professional actors were first
yeah yeah I think majority uh I mean
Jennifer Jason Leigh and bug adaptee I
think the only people everybody I mean
Eric who plays the bail bondsman who's
amazing he that was his bail bonds
office his wife with his wife about the
teenage girl she was yeah that was her
first time which is unbelievable and the
older woman in the ant in the accessor
ride yeah first time right last time
thank me never I think that pretty much
I think everybody
I mean it's an amazing that Jennifer
Vaughn Devi and Elena Hendrix who cast a
lot of people I mean
but when Thalia came any place crystal
it was just so obvious you what we've
auditioned a few different people and
she came in and she just had her
headphones and and that's just like a
table of was like 12 people arrest
people it's very very serious and she's
a teenage girl she's never done it
before and she walks in with her
headphones and she's just like just give
me a minute give me a minute I had a
really stressful day and she just pasted
his paces up and down the room and we're
just sitting there waiting Feder get
over her day were like I was like you
got a job I got a book and she said she
said the other day good thing an
interview and she's like yeah that
morning I just woke up wash my face and
I slayed my dragon that's a sec that's
how believable of her she's amazing
dare I ask did she know who you were she
didn't give any indication whatsoever
the entire time and then I can said that
she was like a huge twilight's and stuff
it was pretty crazy I had absolutely no
idea in the entire as she was she was
super cool she's got like Team Edward
t-shirts and stuff but she just didn't
want you to know it I love that